Okay, so welcome back. Welcome to video
19. We're now going to look at stocks. So
we looked at the world view. We looked at
the sector view. And as we went from the
world view to the sector view in the stock
market, we found that we would have a
predisposition of either bullish, bearish
or market neutral, depending on our views
of UMC.
US, European, Chinese, and in its
entirety, in aggregate, global GDP. And
that predisposition leads us towards
situations in sectors where we may lean
towards cyclicals, i.e. cyclicality in
earnings, or we may lean towards
defensives, i.e. non-cyclicality in
earnings.
But what happens when you go to the next
stage? What happens when you actually open
up a sector and see all of the stocks in a
sector? How do you even know which one
could be the best trade, whether it's long
or short, whether it's in a cyclical or a
defensive sector?
So how do you know this? Well, we're going
to go back to this principle of doing the
least amount of work possible. And doing
the least amount of work possible is
really taking the information in the
market that is the most important and most
relevant information, turning that into
real hard dollars via correct
interpretation.
And what we're going to look at now is
what most people view as a standard
industry metric. We're going to be looking
at price-earnings ratio.
However, what is absolutely apparent in
the world and in the world of trading,
amongst retail traders and even
professional traders, research analysts,
people who really consider themselves
professionals in the world of investment
and trading,
what's really apparent is that actually
the vast vast majority of people really
misinterpret what this metric means.
I really want you to pick up on these
principles. It's very, very important that
you get this principle.
And we're going to go over to the
presentation and have a look at what this
really means and why it's so helpful in
you selecting stocks and selecting trades
once you've got your worldview and your
sector view.
And why it's such a useful tool when we're
trying to stick to this principle of doing
the least amount of work possible to get
the highest amount of return with the
least amount of risk.
So let's go over to the presentation. This
is where it gets a little bit fun. So
we're going to use some analogies that are
really going to stick in your mind to make
these principles stand out so you remember
them forever.
Let's go over to the presentation and I'll
see you after the presentation for a
summary of stock views and how you select
stocks correctly.
Okay, let's go on to stock views. So at
this point we assume that we've got a
worldview and a sector view.
So let's say we've found a sector that we
think is going to outperform the market.
It's not difficult.
You're predispositioned to this point
because you think GDP is going to expand.
So why the hell would you be short
cyclicals if you think GDP is going to
expand?
Of course not. You want to be long
cyclicals.
Remember that statement? Your book has to
perfectly represent your view on the
world?
It always has to. Otherwise, you've got a
portfolio that doesn't agree with what you
think. That's crazy.
So let's assume you think that the market
is going up and you're looking at sectors
that you think will outperform cyclicals.
Now you're looking for stocks within the
sector that you think will outperform. How
do you identify these stocks?
So if we're going to look at these stocks
fundamentally, what's the best way to do
it?
The first thing to look at is PE ratio.
However, PE ratio is one of the most
misunderstood fundamentals in the market
by the vast majority of people.
What's the best way to think of PE ratio?
How much the world is prepared to pay for
the earnings of a company?
The problem is stocks trade all day long,
every day. And in the market, there's a
buyer and at that price, there's a seller,
which means that statement is true in
reverse.
How much is the world prepared to sell the
earnings of that company for? And people
get confused by this all the time.
So let's go through an example. I want you
to imagine that you're now predisposition
to buying cyclicals.
And you pull up this sector and all the
stocks are here with the PE ratios, but
I've taken away the names of the stocks.
So here, the names are supposed to be
here, but I've deleted them because you
should have an opinion on these stocks
immediately.
We'll be explaining why. What do we think
of the stock?
So the sector is on 12 times earnings.
What do we think of this stock on 5.8
times earnings?
So let's, this is a current PE. So this
year. What do we think of that stock on
5.8?
Yep. So it's underperformed so far. Is it
cheap?
Okay. What do we think of the stock that's
on 34 times earnings and the one that's on
23 times earnings?
Are they expensive?
Okay. So with this one, on 5.8, you get a
50% discount to the sector.
With this one on 34 times, you're paying a
300% premium to the sector on valuation.
So which one's cheap and which one's
expensive?
There's the answer.
The two biggest swear words in stock
fundamentals, cheap and expensive.
Nothing is ever cheap. Nothing is ever
expensive.
When you see an analyst on TV saying
something's cheap, turn it off.
When you see his friend saying it's
expensive, turn it off.
They're the biggest swear words on a
trading desk.
Nothing is ever cheap. Nothing is ever
expensive.
Why?
This man gave the answer.
Because the company can go faster and then
it doesn't matter how cheap it is.
No, it's just the quality of the earnings.
So why are people at this very moment, at
this very moment, imagine this as you've
pulled this up at midday on a Wednesday
afternoon and the stocks are trading live
in the market.
There's people buying them, there's people
selling them.
Why are people prepared to pay a 300%
premium for the earnings of this company?
Why?
Because they need it.
Exactly.
Because they're shit hot.
Why are people prepared to sell the
earnings of this company at a 50% discount
to the sector?
Remember, the stock's trading right now.
People are selling it on six times.
No, the quality of their earnings is
terrible.
What the market is saying, the market is
making a statement right now.
So think of all of the research analysts
in the world that cover this stock, who
speak to the company every week,
who have spent hours and hours and days
and days and weeks and weeks building
ridiculous DCF valuations.
And the conclusion they've come to is this
company's amazing.
All of them.
And that they're going to not only meet
their earnings, they're probably going to
blow out their earnings and always beat
for the next five years.
It's all in the price there.
It tells you there what the market thinks.
What about this?
So all the research analysts in the world
who are speaking to the company every day,
week, month, building huge models, writing
300 page research reports,
spending 24 hours a day with their team of
12 people, analyzing one stock.
And the conclusion that they've come to is
it's cheap.
Well, the market conclusion is the
complete opposite.
The market has concluded that this stock
deserves to be on a 50% discount to the
sector because it's rubbish.
And they would rather sell this and buy
this because this company's got growth and
that company has nothing.
And if you take the opposite view, you're
basically making a statement.
I know something that the market doesn't
know.
You don't.
Because it's all in the price there.
Everything that the market thinks is in
that price, in the PE ratio.
So the message you should take from it is
actually the reverse.
Without actually looking at the names of
the companies, you've already identified
which ones the market loves and which ones
the market hates.
So for example, let's go through a few
examples.
In the tech boom of 1999.
When companies were IPO-ing and they had
no earnings, but they were forecast that
in 2003, 4, 5, they were going to earn
something.
So when they came to market, they were on
infinite PE.
Current.
What would have happened if you'd have
shorted that stock in March 1999 when it
IPO-ed?
Huh?
Sorry?
You wouldn't, you'd have been wiped out
and you'd have been sacked.
Because it would have gone up 300% in your
face and you'd have lost your shirt.
People were paying infinite times earnings
for the stock and you argued.
That's a classic example.
That period was littered with people,
professionals, who argued with the market.
But what would have happened if you'd have
just gone long and participated and put a
20% stop loss on the trade and just left
it?
And made it 5% of your portfolio for a
month.
You'd have made a fortune.
You'd have made 15% in your portfolio in a
month.
Because it was up to 300%.
Do you see what I mean?
The market can stay irrational longer than
you can stay solvent.
So if you think that's irrational and
you're shorting it, you're just arguing.
Let's go through a theoretical example.
Let's look at a stock that is trading at
$10 in the market with a $1 earnings
forecast for the year.
And it's January.
And you buy the stock at $10.
They forecasted a dollar of earnings for
the year.
What's the P ratio?
10 times.
Company announces in February that they're
not going to hit a dollar a share for the
year.
Because they've got some problems with the
supply chain.
And they now forecast 90 cents a share in
their earnings.
So what happens?
They've had a profit warning that EPS will
drop by 10% versus expectations.
Where does the stock have to go in order
to maintain a 10 times P ratio?
$9 a share.
A month later, company announces they
won't hit 90 cents a share.
Citing a material change in business
conditions.
And they now forecast 65 cents a share.
Where does the stock have to go to
maintain 10 times P.E.?
$6.50.
And then in May, company announces that
they won't manage to hit 65 cents a share.
And they've lost three key customer
contracts to a competitor.
And they now forecast 1 cent a share.
Where does the company have to go to
maintain its 10 times P.E.?
10 cents.
The stock's down 99% in five months.
However, it's still on 10 times.
Are you starting to understand what P is
all about?
What about in the reverse?
So $10 stock in January with $1 a share
earnings.
They announce in February that they're
going to beat $1 a share.
And they now forecast $1.20.
Where does the stock have to go to
maintain 10 times?
Where does the stock have to go to?
To maintain 10 times.
12.
Company announces in March they're going
to beat $1.20.
Material change in business conditions to
the upside in the last six weeks.
And they now forecast $2 a share.
Where does it have to go to?
To maintain.
And then in May.
The company says.
Last six weeks it's gone crazy again.
And they now forecast $4 for the year.
40 bucks.
The P is exactly the same.
Stock can go from infinity to zero and
still be on the same P.E.
It can go from one to infinity and still
be on the same P.E.
That's why the two words cheap and
expensive are completely ridiculous.
If you buy something that's on a 50%
discount to the sector, you're making a
statement.
I know something that the market doesn't
know.
I must be on the inside.
If you short something where the market's
telling you I'm paying a 200% premium for
the earnings
of this company over the sector, you're
arguing.
You're making the statement that you know
something that the market doesn't know and
you're on the inside.
Because the audience of the entire market
who's doing 10 times more work than you on
every single stock in the world is paying
that.
And selling on the 50% discount.
You'll be the same people.
We're going to go through an example which
is a little bit of entertainment to take
the edge off.
Before we have a break.
Let's go through an example of buying
lingerie on Valentine's Day.
I'll try to use analogies that are going
to stick in your mind forever so you never
screw this up.
So for females of the audience just
pretend that you're actually receiving the
gift.
Yeah.
So imagine you're in the office.
It's 6pm on Valentine's Day.
And you've forgotten to get your
girlfriend, your wife, a Valentine's gift.
But you're about to leave.
You know she's going to be cooking you
dinner in an hour.
And you've got a taxi waiting outside to
quickly go and buy some lingerie from a
department store.
You get to the store and guess what?
Because it's Valentine's Day all the
lingerie is sold out.
Except for 3 items.
There's just 3 items on the same hangar.
And you have to make a choice.
The taxi's got the engine running outside.
She's going to kill you if you're late for
dinner.
There's no way you can go home without a
gift.
So you have to make a choice.
You've got lingerie A, it's $50.
Lingerie B, $150.
Lingerie C, $500.
Males only.
Who buys lingerie C?
Put your hand up.
Who buys lingerie B?
Who buys lingerie A?
So we've identified all the cheap buggers.
You're not allowed to come to the pub
later.
Okay.
Females.
Show of hands.
Who would like to receive?
Lingerie A.
Oh, hello.
Who would like to receive lingerie B?
Who would like to receive lingerie C?
Okay.
Okay, if you've gone for lingerie A,
you've gone for what's perceived to be
cheap.
It's perception.
If you've gone for lingerie C, you've gone
for what's perceived to be the expensive
option.
Lingerie B is neither here nor there.
It's just the average lingerie.
It's just the average lingerie in the
department store.
The key is that the price is just a signal
of the quality.
Price is a signal of quality.
So if I told you now that lingerie A is
70% polyester, 30% cotton, and you're only
going to get to use it three times before
it rips.
And that when you take it home, your
girlfriend won't want to wear it anyway
because it's cheap.
And in 30 minutes time she's going to slap
you around the face and say I'm never
wearing that.
Only one female put her hand up and said
I'd actually want that.
So I prefer that option.
You'd prefer what option?
Because of the thing.
I think about some day the price is going
to go 10 times anyway, and the chance that
the guy
can get what I like right is very clear.
Okay.
So I'm trying to spend a lot of money and
have a stake of money, and we'll get to
the other
guy.
Like what?
I've invested it in TV.
Okay.
Invested it in what, sorry?
Lingerie C.
If I tell you it's 100% pure silk, you're
going to get 50 uses out of it.
Your girlfriend is going to be overwhelmed
when you take it home, and she'll get
changed straight
into it, and you'll be the best boyfriend
for the next three months.
A no longer seems cheap.
It's now expensive.
And B is no longer expensive.
It's now cheap.
But you're actually paying multiples 10
times more for C.
There's absolutely no such thing as cheap
and expensive.
The multiple of the company tells you the
price that the market is willing to pay
for the earnings
of the company.
The quality of the earnings.
That's what they're paying for.
So all you're being told in that message,
when something's on a 300% premium to the
sector, is that they've got the highest
quality earnings in the sector.
So you've got the price that you've got
the price that you've got the price that
you've got to go and find out whether
that's justified, but with the
predisposition that you're probably not
going to find anything to justify shorting
it.
And vice versa on a stock that's cheap or
perceived to be cheap on a big discount to
the sector.
So if you short those stocks on a premium
to the sector, you're arguing with the
market.
You're saying, I think it's expensive,
when the market is saying, well, it
absolutely isn't.
I'm prepared to pay for it.
You're arguing with the rest of the
market.
There's nothing you know in general that
the market doesn't already know about that
stock.
That's why they're paying the price, which
is a signal of the quality of the
earnings.
So we've used the example of the tech
boom.
What about another example?
Stocks like Facebook and Groupon, when
they came to market last year.
So Groupon, the end of 2011, Facebook last
year.
Groupon came on over a hundred times
earnings.
Facebook came to market 125 times earnings
in the IPO.
So you're looking at, we looked at the
sector before, where stocks were on 34
times earnings.
And stocks were on six times earnings.
What about stocks on 125 times earnings?
What about them?
Do we buy them?
Do we short them?
Who cares?
There's 40,000 stocks in the world.
All you're doing when you get sucked in to
buy or sell Facebook is reading
newspapers,
listening to the media and not seeing the
bigger picture.
You don't have to participate.
Just let the market have its fun.
And then deal with it later.
It's one stock out of 40,000 in the world.
There's going to be exceptions.
But as a general rule, you should not be
trying to fight the market.
Look at the valuations.
The valuations literally tell you what the
market thinks.
And all of the work that's been done in
the market is represented by the signal of
the price,
of the quality of the earnings.
You're being told a message.
You take that information and you go and
find out whether it's justified.
If you think it's not justified,
then you've still got to be thinking to
yourself,
I'm fighting the market.
Because it's going to have to be an
unbelievable reason
why you're going to go against the market.
Something that nobody's ever seen or
thought of.
There are exceptions in the world.
Of course.
But you don't have to participate.
Not participating is an option.
Let's have a look at a real-world example.
And it'll start to become a little bit
more clearer
when we look at a real-world example
and we start monitoring how we structure a
trade in the portfolio
after we've looked at the sector.
So we're going to look at BP in the summer
of 2010.
What happened to BP in the summer of 2010?
Yeah, so they had the Deepwater Horizon
oil spill.
The Gulf of Mexico.
What was happening in the summer of 2010?
July, August, September.
We had a trend in the ISM where it was
growing for 11, 12, 13, 14 months above
50.
Signalling to us that GDP was going to be
expanding 12 months from now.
So our world view is bullish.
And QE is on the tape.
QE is starting in September.
QE2.
And we're sitting, watching Bloomberg TV.
And there's a Deepwater Horizon disaster
for BP.
BP goes from £6 to £4 a share.
And every analyst in the market is on TV
saying it's cheap.
You should buy it.
Your view is that the world's going to
expand GDP.
The oil price is going to double.
And you're looking at the energy sector,
looking for stocks to go long in the oil
sector.
Do you buy BP?
Maybe after some time, when the price
stabilises.
Okay, so let's assume the price
Do you buy BP?
Yes.
Okay.
A lot of people did.
In fact, the vast majority of retail
traders still own BP two, three years
later.
The guys who bought it.
Because it first ends up as a trading
position.
Then when it doesn't do anything, it ends
up in your pension.
And you make excuses while you're long it.
But let's have a look at what happened.
That's what the stock did.
And around here, around this time, 400
pence a share.
Everybody was saying BP was cheap and
everyone should buy it.
It was a headline in the Financial Times
several times over.
Every analyst who's anybody in the sector
was on TV, on Bloomberg, CNBC saying it's
cheap.
But you're bullish.
Does BP represent your perfect view on the
world?
This is where you have to stay
disciplined.
That sector we looked at before was the
major integrated oil and gas sector.
And that's exactly the P ratios.
That's a screenshot from August 2010.
I had to save that one and collect it.
Because it was a perfect example.
That was BP.
BP was on six times earnings.
Chevron was on 11.
ConocoPhillips was on 13.
Exxon was on 13.
And Enterprise Oil and Gas was the stock
on 34 times.
Do we buy BP?
Let's see what the answer was.
So for six months after that happened,
what actually happened?
Well, look at all the choices that we
could have had.
Just buy the oils.
Just buy oil.
So long WTI.
The US oil price.
What did that pay over six months?
21%.
What did the S&P pay?
16%.
What did the energy sector pay?
43%.
What did BP pay?
Less than 7%.
You've underperformed the sector.
You've underperformed the market.
And you've underperformed the oil price.
Let's have a look at the sector.
Top 10 holdings of the S&P 500 energy
sector.
The XLE.
Exxon, Chevron, Schlumberger.
Going further down the list.
Hullaburton, National Orwell, Varco.
It says that that's the weightings of the
energy sector.
So what are you paying when you buy that
energy sector?
The two biggest holdings.
Make up 30% roughly.
And we know what they were on.
They were on a sector average multiple of
11, 12 times.
So you're basically paying the sector
average multiple.
Yeah?
So you're paying a 100% premium for the
sector.
And you got six times the return.
Thank you very much.
What else?
What else could we have done?
Well, let's have a look at the stock that
we saw earlier.
Helmrich & Payne.
On the September the 1st, 2010.
Do you remember Helmrich & Payne, the one
we looked at?
That was the rig owner.
The rig owner.
Yeah?
That was up 215%.
At that time, that's the historical PE of
the stock.
At that time it was on 34 times earnings.
In the six months after you got 70% in
H&P.
That was the stock to own.
Not BP.
So why was BP trading on six times?
BP wasn't trading on six times because it
was cheap.
It was trading on six times because
capital in the sector.
Money in the sector.
Was paying for this guy.
Was selling BP to pay for it.
No one in the world that's a professional
wanted to own BP.
Because they knew that they wouldn't get a
return.
Over six, twelve, eighteen months.
When the oil price went up.
But they'd get the return in these guys.
So they sold them.
Got money out of BP.
And put it into these guys.
And they paid 34 times earnings.
And sold BP at six times earnings.
What about the risk you'd have got from
that trade?
Well if you bought WTI.
For the whole of that six month period.
The risk you had on.
Would have been specific to oil.
Supply and demand.
Global supply and demand of oil.
At a macro and micro level as well.
S&P 500.
You would have had market, sector and
stock risk.
The energy sector itself.
You'd have had the supply and demand risk.
Plus the market.
BP.
You would have had supply and demand.
Plus market.
Plus stock risk.
And H&P.
You would have had supply and demand.
Plus market.
Plus stock risk.
And H&P.
You would have had supply and demand.
Market and stock.
And H&P.
You would have had supply and demand.
Market and stock.
But what about if you did on the opposite?
What was the smartest trade of all?
The smartest trade was actually to short
BP.
Do the opposite that everybody else is
telling you to do.
In the mainstream media.
Because nothing's ever cheap.
And nothing's ever expensive.
And BP is cheap for a reason.
So if you'd have actually shorted.
BP.
Against.
Your HP long.
You'd have got.
62%.
Higher than anything else in the sector.
Higher than any other trade.
For a significantly less.
Amount of risk.
Because now you've hedged out over that
entire period.
Market and sector risk.
So if you'd have actually shorted.
BP.
Against.
Your HP long.
You'd have got 62%.
Higher than anything else in the sector.
Higher than any other trade.
For a significantly less.
Amount of risk.
Because now you've hedged out over that
entire period.
Market and sector risk.
That's why BP was on six times.
Because everybody was prepared to sell it.
To get that trade on.
Or trades that are very similar to that.
BP became the cash cow of the sector.
To raise cash to pay for better trades.
That's why when you pulled up the screen.
Every day.
For months on end.
There were people actually selling it at
four pounds.
Who are these people who are selling it at
four pounds?
Who are they?
Are they the fairy godmother?
No.
They're real people.
Who have made a decision.
That BP.
At six times.
Is actually expensive.
And this.
Is actually cheap.
Helmrich and Payne.
On 34 times.
That's a massive lesson in price earnings
ratios.
Never ever forget it.
Yes.
There will be the odd exception.
But don't spend your life trying to
identify the exception.
Spend your life.
Listening to the market.
And what it's telling you.
And go with the trend.
You do that.
You'll be very wealthy.
What about other stocks in the sector?
Well.
If.
Most people in the room.
Where we went through the lingerie
example.
Male and female.
Went for the average return.
You went for the average lingerie.
What if you'd have just gone for the
average stock in the sector.
That was on 11, 12 times.
You would have got slightly less.
Than the sector return.
But significantly higher than BP.
It's no coincidence.
You will see this happen.
Time and time and time again.
10 times more often.
Than you see the exception.
You'll see this happen every day.
In the market.
When you really understand what you're
doing.
Countless times.
When I worked.
On trading floors.
At investment banks.
My research analyst.
In the sectors that I was trading.
Would walk out.
Onto the trading desk.
And present me.
With research notes.
Telling me.
That something's cheap.
Or expensive.
The response of every professional trader.
In that situation.
Is to give them the research note back.
And say.
Get off my desk.
Because nothing is ever cheap.
And nothing is ever expensive.
In fact.
We'd be more likely.
To pick up the phone.
Or walk around.
To some sales people.
And say.
Take the opposite position.
So that's what you do.
That's the exercise.
That you go through.
When you're looking.
At stocks fundamentals.
If you want to.
Please feel free.
To go and get the company's.
Last balance sheet.
Profit and loss.
Cash flow.
Go and look at 25 analysts.
Research reports.
The conclusion you're going to come to is.
It justifies its multiple.
People.
Just let the market.
Do all the work for you.
In BP.
Just imagine.
How much.
Resources.
Went into.
All of the research analysts.
Around the world.
And their conclusion.
Was that BP.
Was cheap.
It's not cheap.
There's a guy selling it.
In the market right now.
Just think of all those resources.
All the money.
And all the investment.
That goes into.
Getting the conclusion.
BP is cheap.
It's not.
The market is telling you.
That it's on six times earnings.
And there's people selling it.
Right now in the market.
Imagine you're sitting there.
An analyst.
You're the oil trader.
At Goldman Sachs.
And the analyst.
Who's had a buy rating on BP.
From six pounds.
All the way down to four pounds.
Walks out.
With a new research report.
And says.
BP's even cheaper at four pounds.
And you go.
No shit Sherlock.
It's down.
Right.
And it's down for a reason.
Because they've got 50 billion dollars.
Of liabilities.
To pay for.
Over the next five years.
Out of.
Out of future earnings.
And I want to sell it.
Because it's not going to make money.
When the oil price goes up.
I want to own HP.
Take your research reports away.
And don't call any clients.
It's embarrassing.
That's.
They're the conversations.
That you'd be having.
On a trading floor.
Right.
Your relative PEs.
Literally tell you.
Everything you need to know.
You don't need to work hard.
Just work smart.
Let the rest of the market.
Work hard for you.
Let them work.
And slave away.
Working out.
Where stocks should be trading for you.
And then.
And then take.
The PE.
As a message.
And interpret it correctly.
It's a life choice.
If you want to go and work at an
investment bank.
And beaver away.
As a research analyst.
For 20 years.
Doing DCF models.
And coming to the conclusion.
That BP is cheap.
Feel free.
I'll sit at home.
Collect all of that information.
By just looking at the PE.
Realise what's going on.
Really.
And sell them to the research analyst.
By doing 30 minutes work.
You don't have to work hard.
You can work smart.
That's the smarter way of working.
And that's what professional traders.
Have figured out.
And they can work smart.
And that's what professional traders.
Have figured out.
Over many, many, many years.
That's why.
That person works in the research
department.
And I worked on the trading department.
I worked on the trading department.
Because he wants to work hard.
And I want to work smart.
It's not a coincidence.
So just remember that lingerie example.
Next Valentine's Day.
And remember every time you pull up.
A table.
With the relative PEs of the sector.
With a big list of stock names.
Forget what the names are.
It just does not matter.
If something's on a 50% discount to its
sector.
It's on a 50% discount for a reason.
Someone is selling it right now in the
market.
And prepared to sell it continually at
that price.
Maybe not someone.
Maybe multiple people.
And if you take the opposite view.
You're arguing.
You're making the statement.
I know something the market doesn't know.
And vice versa.
If it's on a 300% premium to the sector.
You short it.
I know something the market doesn't know.
If it's on a 100% discount.
Samsung catching up.
Yeah.
One reason.
Huh?
Samsung catching up.
Yeah.
One reason.
Because the EPS growth forecast.
For 2012.
Was 22%.
The company had gone X growth.
They'd got all of their growth.
Between 11 and 12.
So now people were selling them.
At a discount to the sector.
And one of the reasons.
Was other.
Tablet makers.
Other smartphone makers.
Were catching up.
But at the same time.
Every single research analyst.
In the market.
Had it as a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
And.
The company.
Was a strong buy.
But.
They were the same.
Research analysts.
Who were picking up.
The phone.
And saying.
We forecast.
22%.
Increase.
In EPS.
For the next year.
What's the logical question.
Why have you not.
Downgraded the stock.
If last year.
A stock.
Had 65% EPS.
Growth.
And you had it.
On a strong buy rating.
And now.
It's got 22% EPS.
Growth.
And you're telling me.
It's got 22% EPS.
Growth.
Because it's in your own.
Forecasts.
Why have you not.
Downgraded the stock.
To a hold.
A market.
Perform.
Huh.
No.
They would have actually.
Been right.
In hindsight.
They would have been right.
Because the stocks.
Been murdered.
So why didn't.
Any research.
Analysts.
In the market.
Downgrade.
The stock.
Going up.
Almost spot on.
Almost there.
It's because.
Apple have got a hundred.
Had a hundred billion dollars.
On the balance sheet.
And they didn't want to.
Piss the company off.
Because they don't want to.
Lose their job.
If.
Apple.
Start taking over.
Companies all over the world.
And the banking division.
Of their company.
Misses out.
On all the M&A business.
Because.
They were the only person.
In the market.
To downgrade it.
And that really.
Pissed Apple off.
So they didn't get.
Any banking business.
Out of it.
I mean.
It's really obvious stuff.
There were 45.
Analysts.
Who had it on a strong buy.
In the US.
And.
I mean.
It's really obvious stuff.
There were 45.
Analysts.
Who had it on a strong buy.
In the US.
Then what happens.
So they were on a discount.
To the sector.
At 12 times.
Everybody in the market.
Was saying they were cheap.
Everybody.
Apple.
Apple's going to be.
The first trillion dollar company.
That's what everybody was saying.
It's cheap on 12 times.
It should be trading at a thousand
dollars.
A share.
Not 650 a share.
And everyone was long.
The whole world was long Apple.
What happened next.
They missed their earnings estimates.
For the first time.
In a decade.
And the stock got murdered.
What about now.
After it's been murdered.
And by the way.
Half of the guys.
Are now downgrading.
Because it's just.
A downgrade is justified.
Because the stocks now moved.
They always react late.
Research analysts.
Always.
You'll very rarely get a research analyst.
after it's been murdered. And by the way,
half of the guys are now downgrading. A
downgrade is justified, because the
stock's now moved. They always react late,
research analysts, always. You'll very
rarely get a research analyst who sticks
their neck on the line and says this stock
is going down, especially a household
favourite like us.
Apple, who's got $100 billion on the
balance sheet. It's a classic example of
PE. So one year before it was on 22 times,
a year later it's on 12 times, and it's
cheap. Well done. It's gone down. Well
done. The multiple's gone down from 22 to
12 in a year. And the conclusion you've
come to is that it's cheap. And you've got
it on a strong buy, but you're the same
person telling me it's cheap.
As everybody else, same person who's
forecasting a 22% rise in EPS, and last
year you were forecasting 65%. So why have
you not downgraded the stock?
Equivalent of bought December 2014 400
strike put options. $25,000 worth and just
stuck them away. And had a bet with a guy
in the States who's one of the biggest
bulls of Apple, and he's all over Twitter
every day.
And had a $25,000 straight out bet with
him that Apple, by the end of 2015, will
be below 400, when it was at 650. And he
took the bet.
So if it's above 400 at the end of 2015,
I've got to pay him $25,000 in cash. And
I've got to take him out for dinner
anywhere in London. He's in New York. And
he's got to do the reverse if it's below
400.
Where's Apple now? 430. Now he doesn't
know what to do. Why? Because if he hedges
that position by shorting Apple, and it
goes to 550, and then it goes to 300, he's
going to lose even more money.
Because he'll just get stopped out all the
way up.
What about the put position? How much has
that made?
350%.
Wasn't a big position. Tiny amount in the
portfolio. Stick it away. Forget about it.
That was done September and October, just
scaling into the position very slowly as
the stock was falling.
It's paid over 100 grand from a $25,000
position.
Have I hedged the delta? No. Couldn't care
less.
That is a classic example of PE.
When you get a bit more sophisticated, you
can go and do those trades.
But,
Apple on 22 times in 2011,
on 12 times in 2012.
Take that as a huge message.
You know, gathering all that information
as well,
when I was in China during the Olympics in
August,
I didn't want to be in London during the
Olympics,
because I thought it would be a waste of
time.
So I went to China to do something that
would actually use my time efficiently.
And every person I met
was getting rid of all of their Apple
products,
and getting Samsung products.
Samsung are growing 10 times faster than
Apple in China.
So when I got back,
I started looking for what bets I could
put on,
without actually being exposed to shorting
the stock.
I wanted to look out further in the
calendar and just have a bet
where I don't have to think about it for
over a year.
So I just bought massively
out-of-the-money put options.
18 months out.
And just forget about it.
Three months later,
killing it.
That's a massive message of PE.
Apple is the classic example of the last
year.
You could not pick up a newspaper,
you could not put the TV on,
and not hear an analyst saying it's cheap.
Not one person in the world said Apple
will go to 400.
And now they're all downgrading it.
Six months later.
That's how the market works.
Okay.
In terms of resources and downloads,
you're going to get a spreadsheet called
sectors with all the live links in it.
So you can go and look at every sector in
the world.
And it takes you direct to websites that
give you all the valuations with all the
stocks.
And you can use the company stats for US,
Europe, and emerging markets.
Where do you get your PEs from?
Yahoo Finance gives you PE multiples.
YCharts gives you the historical PE
multiples.
NASDAQ.com gives you so much more.
NASDAQ.com gives you a lot of stuff.
Gives you the whole landscape of all the
research analysts.
What they're forecasting.
What their recommendations are.
What the consensus PE estimates are.
For the year and next year and the year
after.
NASDAQ.com is a great resource.
MarketWatch.com as well.
They'll give you everything.
If all else fails and you can't get the
PE.
Anywhere publicly, online.
Pick up the telephone.
You're allowed to speak to people.
Pick up the telephone and call the
company.
Every public company has an investor
relations department.
And they have a fiduciary duty to answer
your questions.
Pick up the phone and tell them you're a
shareholder.
And just say, what are the consensus
estimates from the market for your
earnings for the next year?
And they have to tell you.
If they don't, it's illegal.
I'm not joking.
I actually used to have to do this when I
was a teenager.
Because there was no internet.
Well, there was, but it was a pound a
minute to plug it in.
So, you pick up the telephone.
And I was 16, 17 years old.
And I'd speak to the finance directors and
investor relations department of Vodafone.
And say, I'm a shareholder.
Tell me what your forecasts are.
What the market's forecasts are for the
next year.
And they have to tell you.
Has anybody ever worked in an investor
relations department?
If you ever do, you'll see that they just
sit around doing nothing all day anyway.
If they get an incoming call, they'll be
really excited.
So, if all else fails, just pick up the
telephone.
You're allowed.
Current this year and forward one year.
Because when you start to get halfway
through the year,
next year starts to become more relevant.
Once a company's reported two quarters for
the year,
the forward PE becomes more relevant.
Because it's starting to get to a point
where it's known what the year's going to
look like for the stock.
After Q3, it's all about next year.
Q4 is irrelevant.
Because you're always looking six, 12
months ahead.
Okay, so welcome back.
Hope you enjoyed that.
The analogies that we use are obviously a
little bit entertaining.
But they're entertaining for a reason.
Because this principle is so important
that nothing is ever cheap.
Nothing is ever expensive.
This principle is so important that we
need to make this entertaining so you
absolutely remember it.
Now, this is something, the principle of
being cheap and expensive, you really,
really have to grasp this.
I can't stress this enough.
If you ever, ever say something is cheap
or expensive, you really need to give
yourself a slap.
Because they are the biggest curse words
in the world of professional trading.
Nothing is ever cheap.
Nothing is ever expensive.
When we went through those examples, the
theoretical example of a stock with a PE
of 10.
And it can be on a PE of 10 all the way
down to one cent.
It can be on a PE all the way down to
basically zero.
And on the opposite side, a stock can be
on the same PE forever all the way up.
And it can be on the same PE all the way
to infinity, theoretically.
So, when you hear somebody telling you
something is cheap or telling you
something is expensive,
you now know how to interpret what they're
saying.
What they're telling you is actually
nonsense.
So, a lot of research analysts will go out
and do tons and tons of work,
write 100, 200 page research reports and
deduce that something is cheap.
And then they'll go and buy it or they'll
convince people to buy it.
But then it never actually makes any money
whatsoever.
What you actually should probably be
thinking of doing in those situations
is looking for the real assets that you
should be purchasing
and potentially even using that cheap
asset that you're being told is a great
investment or a great trade.
You may even look to use that cheap asset,
like in the BP example,
as a hedge against a purchase which is at
a premium to the sector for a very good
reason.
That's a very, very important principle.
Please bear in mind and really try and
grasp that there's nothing in the world
that's cheap.
There's nothing in the world that's
expensive.
That's expensive.
Because one man's cheap is another man's
expensive and one man's expensive is
another man's cheap.
It's just perceived value.
And one of the classic examples at the
moment, well, in recent times, has been
Apple.
Apple was an absolute classic example of
this in 2012.
So from 2011 to 2012, Apple's EPS growth
was forecast to be 60% plus.
All the research analysts that were
covering the stock, which were about 45
analysts in total,
were all forecasting 60% plus EPS growth
in 2011 for 2011 to 2012.
Every single one of those analysts had a
recommendation of a strong buy or a buy on
the stock.
Now, Apple in 2011 at $350, $400 a share
was trading on 22 times earnings, 22 times
forward earnings.
And then in 2012, when the stock was at
$650 a share, the stock was trading on 12,
13 times earnings, forward earnings.
Why?
Because the EPS growth forecast for Apple
from 2012 to 2013 was actually 22%.
Around 22% average amongst all of the same
analysts.
So you have to connect the dots here and
really ask the question.
If the same analysts had a stock, and it
doesn't matter what the stock's name is,
if the same analysts had a stock that was
promising 65% EPS growth from 2011 to
2012,
and they were recommending a strong buy
recommendation or a buy recommendation on
that stock,
and the same analysts a year later had 22%
EPS growth.
How can the same analysts not downgrade
the stock?
Because in that situation, the stock has
actually peaked in terms of its growth
potential.
And at the time, in the summer of 2012,
everybody was saying Apple was cheap.
Everybody.
Apple on 12, 13 times earnings is too
cheap.
It's trading on a discount to the sector.
It should be $1,000 a share.
As soon as that happened, any professional
trader with any knowledge or sense of
valuation,
and in the professional trading world, any
knowledge or sense of how the world of
trading really, really works,
was looking at that and thinking at that
time, Apple is cheap for a reason.
And the reasons were very, very obvious,
because their EPS growth was declining at
a rapid pace,
or forecasted to decline at a rapid pace.
And all the retail traders in the world
got caught out.
The vast majority of retail traders were
long Apple, and they got caught out and
lost a lot of money on the way down.
Probably the same guys that made quite a
bit of money on the way up.
But net-net, what actually happened?
Well, most retail traders probably came
out of the entire Apple situation not
really making much money over a two, three
year period.
So, that serves as a really classic
example of why something is never cheap,
and why something is never expensive.
Now, we used the examples as well, of the
tech boom, and Facebook, and Groupon, and
we made this statement.
The market can stay irrational longer than
you can stay solvent.
Don't argue with the market, because the
market is telling you the price.
And the price of the PE is a signal of
quality.
So, please never, ever say something is
cheap or expensive.
Don't argue with the market.
There's 40,000 stocks in the world.
If you want to argue, go and argue with
somebody else.
Because if you argue with the market,
you're just going to get run over.
Don't participate.
That is an option as well.
There's 40,000 stocks in the world.
Kick back.
Don't worry about it.
If something seems expensive or something
seems cheap, you can always not
participate.
That is another option.
You're spoiled for choice here.
There's 40,000 stocks in the world.
Okay, we're going to move on now.
We're going to move on to the next video.
And I'm going to see you in video number
20.
And please try and grasp all of these
situations.
Rewind the video.
Watch it again.
Make sure you get this concept that
nothing is ever cheap or expensive.
And I'll see you in video 20.